welcome to this video its yacht Burt
okay yeah but I have 31 games against
him I'm on a minus four score so not a
terrible but last last couple of games
didn't fare so well okay the 85 line is
what I what I normally play let's see 93
is in inches this is very interesting
very interesting way to play it for I
have forgotten the precise move on I
think this is right a form attending a 3
which basically forces wise to play a 3
himself check yeah and one funny point
of this early April pushes that you can
get in can get in route a5 funny idea
rookie a 5 crenate i'm going to do that
just because it's cool i don't know if
it is so great but it is a funny way to
play at least while let's say funniest
maybe the room but it's it's an original
way to play something that you don't see
every day I it's not so easy know maybe
I'm actually threatening to take on a
three yeah he he reacted it was a he
reacted to it do I play Bishop efore now
for a trade of bishops it's not a bad
idea I can also play g5g for ya winning
a pawn basically it's not a not bad
maybe I can do that
or g5 h5 let's do that it's interesting
note that my look on a5 is covering the
g5 porn isn't quite neat yeah so here i
was thinking i can i can also take by
the way okay this was my original idea
so i'm going to do it and now i can take
you to form for interesting play I don't
know maybe I should have just played we
should be formed Fisher before was the
better move against yard blood against
such a dynamic player maybe this is this
is interesting but it is very very murky
which suits his style pretty sure so I'm
playing a little bit with fire here
let's see let's see what is coming up
with I mean I don't really think that
white has enough for the porn but it is
um it is something that he probably
likes this type of position okay do i
take i have bishop c6 come on let's do
that asking him if he really wants to
take on 85 giving me queen a 50 AC
sacrificing the exchange maybe he is
right they probably would sacrifice the
exchange and taking all going back okay
so okay I thought lighty for might be a
move or is this is stupid 94 d5 I can
actually take 525
I don't know 94 looks nice if I get it
in 55 and I can also i can take g5 pawn
takes what I'm what a mess yeah this is
a problem the position gets totally
messy and he is definitely better sorry
in this kind of position that I am in a
positional struggle I don't really mind
mind to play him but when it gets get
some gets murky is definitely definitely
the better player ok let's see an ID
five is the move I guess I mean I don't
really know what how to assess the
position after d5 but this is what white
needs to do I guess otherwise I probably
take g5 play Bishop reform form for some
very welcome trades
adi 595 hg5 then i take a couple of
times on d5 it's probably not really
enough oh he's allowing that okay taking
not spending tons of time now i am happy
to get this stuff traded so i'm kicking
him back here with f6 and d5 and stuff
come on let's do that let's see not
getting too far behind on the clock now
f 54 if he takes Knight c5 that's
actually looking nice or is this too
loose I don't know I don't know I have
no time don't want to fall too far
behind d 595 is my idea and I can take
now okay let's get steak here first then
I take on e4 that's very loose okay
what I want to do is I want to okay its
okay its opposite the idea is not
important now anymore okay does not
cannot enter really on 95 95 493 that's
actually nice right might be three might
be might be nice him and I maybe have d5
kicking the eyes and cream before anyway
anyway that's not a bad move to play
probably no don't be three years is
something irritating white resins
obviously very irritating is it really
that bad hmm I mean I like my position
but I wasn't really sure how bad it is
maybe it is that bad I mean but he has
some want so many physicians against me
out of murky murky positions yeah it's
hard for him to make a move really that
that's true computer as on- form but I'm
always very alert against him because of
his very strong play in dynamic
positions but 95 was probably good yeah
let's let's have a look him at the cause
of the game here Queenie to hear was
here also I had the possibility just
played in a very positional way in a
strategic way just just trading this
bishop which wouldn't be bad yeah i'm
trading those bishops and the sea for
porn and the process is a little bit
weakened but i think this is better and
the computer also approves of this idea
and basically says that white has no
sufficient compensation yeah maybe this
is really true i am ok this is true
because of a tactic that I've quite
typically missed 94 as a good move here
very good move actually interesting f
this is a very nice move the idea is
that
k Luke takes is very nice and ok if he
does not take the bishop I mean I'm
threatening 95 Bishop b4 at 93 it's not
so easy to make a move here actually the
computer wants to play f4 and after that
i'm still almost winning this is this is
a position here that we almost got in
the game the this kind of structure just
with a couple of extra moves for black
yeah i went back back and 94 so i could
have gotten this with a couple of more
couple of extra extra moves but this is
strategically it's very nice iie 5 was
even stronger to threaten f 60 km but i
wanted to make a couple of quick moves
and I mean this is this keeps a big
advantage but the other one was stronger
yeah k route b5 can this may be
debatable but it keeps a big advantage
the problem is that this bishop in
particular it's not doing anything and
whenever he takes the problem is that it
gives my night very crucial squares so
he some he's really in big trouble and
Ti n95 was stronger at first I wanted to
play rook c8 which is not bad but this
is stronger it definitely is the
computer what is the computers move here
what does if it doesn't want to do
Queenie to okay yeah well I can check
check check yeah and in this kind of
position I mean if everything else fails
i'm trading queens it's not the best
move back this is this is winning for
black simply because of this nonsensical
bishop I'm getting night over here
there's a technical wind from black yeah
so he probably didn't resign to earlier
still still a surprise when they give up
and without really an obvious loss ok I
hope you enjoyed it thanks for watching